um
um
what do you think before we get started
please stay off your cell phones no
happily and keep table talk to a little
now who's ready to see other people
this stuff has a professional day now so
he's here to help you out
get it up on those hot stream
thank you guys for coming tonight my
name is hans pim and welcome to other
people
where we make people date whether they
want to or not
we mix up the names of the bucket and
then two random people go on a date for
one minute and then afterwards we
interview them and find out why they are
the way they are
this is going to be a lot of fun we're
going to have a great time our guest for
tonight
very funny and kill tony veteran she a
lot of people say that she should be the
new regular i say
that's a nice thing that's why
that's a nice thing to say and she
deserves it
funny a very funny comedian give it up
for molly vivint
how are you doing molly
great how are you oh you know cancer
poultry and all that
yeah it's fun good simplicity yeah any
publicity is good publicity
i actually was cancelled all the way
here actually what i call a homeless
person at pogo
i think that's two cute little words
right
makes you think that they're prancing in
a daisy field
something like that
well i can't use any smart refrigerators
so
anyways are you guys ready to see a real
live human date
uh there's only one name in the lgbt
bucket
i'm sorry
this is still texas
[Music]
please don't cancel me the woman is
monica moran
he's done it before he'll do it again he
can't be stopped
it's cody and monica moran
going on a date together
all right one minute
and go
i like your jacket because it seems very
sporty are you into obscure sport uh no
it was given to me okay yeah um yeah
thank you where are you from uh i'm from
here my whole life
wow no one's here i know it's especially
weird now i mean oh i'm from california
yeah people you guys what are you doing
well i'm from dallas so that's possible
yeah
yeah but i've lived here for like two
and a half years now so okay but yeah
you're done
yes
i guess
uh what will you like to do in austin
uh honestly this campaign actually like
you call me shows yeah yes the audience
which is important
not something i'm super big on what it's
all about pushing my personal boundaries
and personal development development and
all that stuff way to go uh yeah this is
out of my comfort zone
we're here together outside of our
mutual company
do you think it's morning right now
oh wow
you're really doing great cody she's my
gonna get right now it makes perfect i
disagree with your last point hans any
woman that comes up here could stop
what was my last point he said i can't
be stopped i can be stopped by any woman
here
okay good to know when enemies
he can't be stopped
there is a self-destruct button on this
coding machine
when was the last time a lady stalked
you
was it when you vomited during
intercourse
yeah
or was it on the street and she told you
to smile well
first one
uh cody you asked uh you asked if she
was uh into sports
she quickly denied you sure
unfortunately
it's just
the front i have today again
it's a very sleek jacket i like it it
looks very nice she had the right idea
though you have like a sporty spice look
to eat too but i don't know
it's cute
do you uh what do you do besides sport
and you don't do any sports but yeah
what do you think we call your freedom
i guess that's a sport but i can do that
anymore into the olympics yeah just now
i can still identify as a rock climber
he's so supportive of you
i just want you to know that that's like
it's really
he's a good guy i feel like uh she's
like renee brown or something
terrible if not culture who is that
she's like a speaker she talks about
vulnerability and shame i feel like get
to her
vulnerable shame
you're talking about pushing your
personal
boundaries so that's cool yes
open-minded guy and you look like you're
from austin yes
my whole life it used to look a lot more
square
put it that way but definitely it's like
hans can't go away i used to be a good
boy
i could work at an engineering firm
right now you never know
cody on the other hand you look like a
mug shot
right when's the last time i got
arrested
i've never been arrested
i was too young to be arrested the
closest i ever got i was
you never see young to be arrested
uh what were you doing when you were too
young to be arrested well the report
said to your race after that i don't
know
on a date it was just oh no this wasn't
an idea
okay
so the fbi stopped to cody can be
stopped by ladies and the fbi
um
i'm glad that uh you've uh abandoned
your terroristic ways
and now you're a noble member of society
uh monica how's your dating life been
are you uh currently single
number one
one of the most famous fake contestants
that are not in a relationship to sign
up for their show anyway making a
mockery in the forums
it's been a while but they're on a date
yeah is this the most awkward
conversation you've had
in a while
do you have worse
where
you know i guess just like on a regular
basis people just are awkward sometimes
what what do you do whereas people are
so awkward all the time
well okay so i like
give economy i go to people's homes and
i do like home improvement jobs for them
so i feed a lot of people like from
different types of papers people just
don't
communicate with others
work force all taskrabbit taskrabbits
and do a lot of the hoarders look like
cody
no they're usually all lazy
yeah
they don't like you are you order no no
i i do kind of think about like
salvage and uh thrifting i think that's
the one that awesome actually supposed
to call birthday
yes i'm not i'm not scavenging garbage
i'm drifting
absolutely
go clean your room they were actually
training you for your job
were you a good uh room cleaner as a
child
like
sometimes i'm doing a job and i'm like
dude my mom used to make me do this when
she was mad at me like she'd like make
me deep clean things and like reorganize
things
one hungry thirst of capitalism that's
making you do it that's right well now
you've reclaimed your trauma that's
right yeah you know i guess in a way
wait i have a question so if you were
dating a guy well i know you're
dating went home after our first date
and they had like a messy room
and that like did you just go to work
you didn't go into like
to change yeah
it depends how bad it is i guess if it's
like really bad it's like no you can't
be helped but
i guess yeah i mean sometimes it's fun
to like
fix people's [ __ ] that'll move well
you're in luck because we got cody okay
that's a lot of [ __ ] to mix
no i'm just kidding cody you've actually
got a good job
believe it or not
hey
department eventually that's the like
career goal path
but right now all the writing i do is
just telling people i'm sorry your game
experience is unfortunate here are the
hell options
do you like ratcheting clank
i do though that is one of the game
series i haven't actually played i've
only had my proxy experience through my
friends because i never had playstation
what about atv offroad fury too
no i'm sorry those are the only video
games i've ever played about
opera jerry
you don't want to hurt molly boone off
road
we've got that fury
um
so you guys uh what do you guys think
about uh second date where would you
guys go if you were to go if you were
single well i feel like you have like
motorcycle riding vibes and i also so we
should like ride motorcycles together
that would be fun right you have a
motorcycle i have a scooter okay we
could do a scooter right now oh yeah
i imagine monica's driving and coming
standing young
we could scoot her to a rock gym because
i i don't i often don't consider myself
a climber anymore either but it's a fun
hobby
for sure
nice
yeah that would be awesome
say and then for dessert you clean
history
exactly
he looks white as [ __ ]
are you are you white as well
so this one's sort of like once you go
white you don't you don't go right
yes i yeah i mainly date white boys i
guess i've been with him for four years
so
that's awesome i was not expecting
someone so pale
i am
but uh cody had a chance but it looks
like she has a type
i know cody what was your last
relationship
my first relationship was uh cheating
redhead
uh so uh
how did she cheat on you
well she started getting into martial
arts and then she went to go practice
martial arts with
various people she was in the martial
arts while i was the one who with the
real job working the whole time
was he asian
i don't know honestly
[Music]
like
i guess she did it and that's over
how did you find out
she told me she eventually kind of
messed up the candy
well so
the really long story i can't go into
what her family ended up going into our
apartment
why yeah
um and after about the whole family been
cheating on you the mom was [ __ ] slow
on the dad
the first perspective was the three
bedroom apartment and there was me and
her and a roommate and then the roommate
moved out to make room for her mother
her father her younger siblings and then
her grandparents didn't sleep there but
then came and spent the day there from
about 6 a.m to 8 p.m every day it's
called a family
yes i don't remember
very and then she like you know
like 17 people all related to someone
you know
24 to 25 in that year of my life that
was happening that that was depressing
it was and like it's not gonna help you
on your date
why wouldn't
i can tell thank you very soon you don't
even think about it anymore
unless someone brings up your last
relationship
thanks how much kids you haven't locked
and loaded
i i don't think that uh that's cool and
i'm on your side
yeah i can just really live with it if
that helps uh take that with you
uh monica how did you uh like the date
what did you think about the overall
experience i mean it's really odd like
having a conversation with someone in
front of other people but you were very
nice thank you that's that's the goal to
come off this nice and healing
nice guy
cody and monica moran thank you guys so
much for coming out give it up for the
probability of my technology
you're going on a date together
i think they liked each other
they were cute
just a reminder you can sign up any time
the more the merrier let's get let's get
it going you want to choose the name
i don't know which one i have under the
dudes i think
we got thomas cortez how's the dude
[Music]
simon
you guys taima
slime man
uh this should be a good date
i don't know any of them
there's no other people veterans here
so it should be completely organic
she's signing up for a lot of people i
hope they all can spend
all right she's flirting with monica
give them for mommy cortez and
stein man
i'ma
dude do i start and go
okay so what's your favorite color
it's green what is your favorite color i
don't have one but that person
yes i actually am a cat person oh
costume i have zero cats i just think
they're really grillable oh you should
get one do you have a cat i have a cat
stroller in my car actually a cat
stroller yeah yeah so you do have cats
yeah i have two
but they they have a stroller they call
me and
well they got
yeah so uh when you're where do you
usually use your cat stroller does it
get used in a park only are you ever
like taking
i think it's cool i think it's great i i
just want to know more about him um
really you know actually i think
i want to know more about the cat
stroller that's you kind of uh it was
your second question with the cast on
the scene oh that's funny because i
think i scared the last person away when
i said i have a casserole and so i'm
like okay i'll start with you know i'm
gonna scare them away
yeah
make them uncomfortable
beautiful people
thomas you did your hair today you got
your harry potter glasses on
did you uh did you know you were going
to come on a date
bucket didn't happen
that's the secret we try to keep pinning
it's all part of the illusion
you can check us out on youtube
head out to all the kim spells out there
that's what i call my fans
spyma
uh
right i'm just uh noticing cancel you on
twitter she's gonna cancel me thomas
you're doing way better with simon than
i am uh
what uh what made you sign up tonight
are you uh single that'd be
nice
i've been wanting to go to comedy shows
and i was like this is an interesting
one let's see how funny it's gonna be
okay a lot of pressure now yeah
what uh what what's like the funniest
thing a guy's done on a date that that
you remember
can laugh with
weirdest
we're at the we're at the swimming like
at a public swimming pool what is going
on here there's swimsuits underneath
when he was naked
bottom down yes
he was winning
thomas are you gonna do that
sexual uh vidcon dex
i like how you say you took his pants
off like like he flashed i guess that's
a good way to say it he flashed here
that's like a that's like a sex crime
and it's probably
that's how their brains work so maybe
like
oh you know i don't think it's 21 year
olds always taking their pants off each
other
do you think it was an accident like you
know sometimes you take out a sweater
and there's like a shirt that gets stuck
to it and everyone sees your heels like
that
why that's right i didn't mean to cut
you off that was really the question
i got this island
it means too sounds like you didn't take
them off
but
what
honestly two kids didn't walk by while i
was trying to figure out how to like
handle the situation oh my
goodness poor children i traumatized
probably these kids were traumatized
keep your pants on this time
it's spilled out on youtube
look at thomas he's boring as [ __ ] let's
talk more about you
though is you look like the nicest
person like you look like what my mom
would draw from my sister today
thank you
that'll take your pants off on thursday
yeah i mean welcome to this story
this chance there's a rubik's cube we're
going to have an iq of 240 to get in
there thomas are you do you have a kink
are you are you into fetishes
uh no vanilla's been doing it for me
missionary
what kind of girls
uh i like all girls there's really not
disneys
like that but hawaii was captured
she
yeah they've been all around the same
age range you know like my age
i'm 28
hey that's a good age
i'm not i'm just reading
hell over here
simon i think molly's trying to steal
your man
you gotta fight for him all right please
this is going really well for me
oh you're doing amazing you're i think
you're winning the show
that was the point i think
that's all you're doing great uh thyma
you have a casserole alert
so is it because you want the cats to go
out but you they don't wobble on a
leash i just
for some reason i wanted a cat that's
like a dog i could have gotten a dog i
don't know why i went with cat but
yeah he's getting old enough they're
gonna go paddle boarding this summer
and it's constantly it's not only
because of your cats it's just the way
you talk about your cats that's like
crazy
thank you yes that's probably what means
like how i get all this show penis
you said uh you said that your favorite
color is green
uh yes that's true that's my
favorite color
you guys have so much in common
simon your favorite color green as well
i can see she's as vicious of this
character
when simon first came up here that's
what she asked you she was like is your
name in the bucket no no no
yeah interesting
are you uh are you uh
did you cheat in college
through college yeah oh i did not think
wow i worked for my grades i'm asian
though
no i cheated heavily
um
[Music]
what's your favorite word in urdu
that's the language in pakistan
[Music]
all right
do you actually love cats were you just
trying to be like a nice date uh no i
actually like cats
okay can i take everything i said back
oh okay you don't like cats you're still
very appealing
but it's it's dog i'm sorry that i'm
broken
that's okay we can still uh
taking a generous dolphin
we're getting it on right now
i'm just gonna see it
uh thomas uh so you're like a
theoretical cat person you don't have
one have you ever seen one
probably a campus
that's not happening
so you're you're just like i i think i'm
a cat person but you've never been like
no cameras
okay let's just say that there's a cat
purring in front of you what's your
petting technique
it's on the table it's on top of the
table all right
yes
normally i go like a with a light touch
because cats can [ __ ] you up
and you can start with your top
technique you know you gotta just go
with like your most
your most uh not get scratched a little
too like one of these
it's more like this you get the little
little pet you you give it like a two
second little two seconds it's a premier
league one gets your bounce off yeah
and then and then what do you do
i go with the
old in the ear
down to the tail
full
what a naughty point
all right i set myself up for this one
and then you're rubbing around and
everything
does that move work was that a good one
no
that's just a metaphor for
eating and eating [ __ ] so yeah i'll
change up those two straps i can teach
you
[Music]
thomas's girlfriend
um he's an actual musical person
and simon's actually cheerful too
no i am sorry okay
yeah don't forget your relationship
status
she was having a visual segment
i flipped this table over
what um what kind of uh relationships uh
have you been in are you uh is there a
lot of arranged marriages in uh pakistan
i am first generation who has not
married yet so i am
what are you
oh like for my job
i'm a tech sale though
as well
on the team
she could be here
[Music]
she might need an health care tutor
you're too good looking to be a teacher
man that's probably people
[Music]
[Music]
oh
well that's the lie
let's assume you walk in and uh molly is
a family member and you're counseling
her what is your first move
[Music]
plug them through the door and you ask
them what's your [ __ ] attention spot
okay
what is your relationship like
we
thank
okay thomas now assuming that she's a
student that can't figure out the
quality of the question
oh
[Music]
whatever monica moran's first date or
whatever okay that was you actually um
yeah go ahead and
okay so i guess first i would look at
her work and
see if she
was down there read the book process i'm
sorry what
talk to her talk to your student um okay
so what i would ask well they don't
stand first of course they're going to
just be kind of silent and do this
because most of them are stop explaining
and then talk to me okay so well what do
you not understand i'm tutoring her
okay
okay so what does that mean
[Music]
all right well and look at your
reference you can look at your reference
sheet for me
um i think it's a squared plus b squared
plus
nc 920
[Applause]
so uh were you good at this as a student
is that why you were like i gotta start
teaching this [ __ ] so bad nice
yeah we can tell
thanks i think
did you do any grubs in high school
uh no not really actually wow all these
students would never do drugs in many
struggles not america
you try to fit in you try to
straight legs
this is what kelly looked like before
his transformation
hey look forward to that
okay thank you square you're saying it
looks like this american one
that's if you guys were calling me
attraction
you're very cute
you're a very cute square you're all the
squares i was talking about ace baby my
knee is there
okay
diagrams here and then he thinks about
squares
i guess it's a sort of square base
because like these sides of the
triangle's alternators square
it's like two drugs
which is
six
but you're higher than six
you're like
an eight and a half
in school yes cody
oh my favorite was math
yeah
i wasn't very i'm autistic
uh what was your favorite subject
school
were you like in the cheerleading
section where you like kicking kicking
your
feet up real high and stuff
so i look
that means you're a cheerleader in the
past if you carry the two
in all words
yeah
of you have any diagnosed mental illness
i do
you one of the apotheons phd i'm
guessing post td would be adrenaline
[Music]
that's like not normal just like
maybe step away or
no breathing techniques actually work
and stuff like i'll just follow the
structures and go so they're
certainly nothing see
what are the women nice
[Music]
you have adhd and anxiety
that's impressive that's your victorian
[Music]
sounds
food and stuff to
get the squirrels away spicy food is
that where your mom lives
no just family over there
[Music]
[Music]
uh what do you think about the back seat
are you getting another booster
[Music]
this guy splits his hair back showers
and
knees
[Music]
when joey gained
lee darwin
do you do you know joey
oh my god what are you doing
strip dancing
do you guys know each other
uh
here comes joey
gaith coming up off stage
look at those long legs give a number a
joint and uh
and try to [ __ ] each other
you better spoke
i like red
[Applause]
very cute
she's too cute
she thinks that she can uh
go on a date and make my body
reservations
i don't know
[Music]
together
[Music]
you do paperwork you uh answer emails do
you answer emails i do wrong paperwork
let's hope you're doing the right kind
of paperwork to help the uh ones that
destroy the planet
um
welcome art i'm a choreographer
you do choreographing dancing yes and
that's what you did tonight for us
god damn like swinging your legs over in
the slowest way possible
i think uh joey had a better entrance he
[ __ ] linked it up here he
was that nice costume
looked like uh this
and johnny mom and something i really
appreciate it
i started shooting there
so are you more of an athlete or
regardless honestly i just found out
dylan and matthew
yeah i was going to say that
dancing
i feel like i'm on the set of euphoria
right now
really making me euphoric
how slow your [ __ ] time
oh my god
just don't think like my name isn't all
you just do slow dancing
so stay with your [ __ ] name that's
right no no i don't know it's about
writing thanks yeah
[Music]
no i think you'd be too scared
so i don't
they're hearing voices they're on drugs
they're talking slowly i think they did
nitrous yes
how did you fall into choreography
uh i just been dancing since i was
little
just in front of the tv long time do you
like the cheating girls
no more
myself
nothing's slowly disappointing
they're sick
it actually is
it's like bring it on but
oh you're just um
yeah i'll stop there
uh so can you show us anything that
would impress us something we can't do
we can all
link it up on
uh what kind of music do you dance to
some hip-hop can we get some hip-hop
dance music
free preferably
you're already on the spot you're on
stage
you have nothing to offer verbally and
not good
it's always slow
so i'm wondering if you have anything
physical
some uh choreography maybe you could
teach us all how to do a tick-tock dance
right man
stand up you know
we're all waiting for you and you're
letting us down
all right let's go
oh you're the choreographer you teach us
teach us what to do
[Music]
let's get the governor oh there you go
hello hello wave action
you'll agree
[Music]
crazy
oh
is
great
we waited a lot a lot of time for you to
do this books
uh at least uh so what kind of music do
you usually dance to
like what like i'll show you
i do love usher who doesn't love it uh
junkie actually
mario
he's honest
yeah you got you got the uh
[Music]
the energy for a rave
they can't contain you
do you like skrillex
no no i don't like girls
virtual riots stuff like that okay
yeah that's you should check out vogue
it's pretty fun actually i actually am
there every day
what comedy
really
thoughts hate money there
anybody
that's a name
i understood you'll find that
i don't see that dude i've never been
there
being
saying
well on their everyday listening
thank you guys so much for coming out
and now you know what we do
[Music]
your good name
i hope that
you can actually dance with him
ah what a date
that was the worst date i've ever been
working
what the [ __ ] was that
were just staring at each other at us
they were staring at us who goes on a
date and staring at other people
they come from different sides of the
room that's a good sign they don't know
each other
[Music]
yeah do you go on a lot of live dates
first this is a first to me and it's not
why it's the error yeah i'm here tell
you what i learned this
there you go now you can
not squint when
just for like your recreational time
just meaning so you haven't been back to
this alicia listen
i'm
how long have you been here turned
double court so wow
that's terrible at eight
hey they were saying
yes i've been there in time
we interrupted them it's finding out
where they've been how long they've been
here we were getting help
because we're about to exchange social
security numbers
but unfortunately we have to step in for
a minute the minute is sacred you gotta
respect a minute
he said uh i'm gonna sit here in front
of light so that you don't have to
squint
and then you look directly at me after
you settle
honestly i i'm not on stage so often i
uh
just been looking around i suppose
like an excuse
yeah i very rarely am on a stage you
know well don't look at the asian man
right after you say it went
down too
many little lies
i feel like you guys both have uh
rich parents
that's the
[Music]
i i actually don't use my sunblock but
what is
[Applause]
it's gonna be the new let's go brandon
you're gonna sign live
hey you gotta plop your best okay what
is this
that was the baby we just we just did it
um
oh my god
you don't deserve your purse back
uh you said that you're not used to this
location because it used to be called
something else we actually don't they
look like
a foreign
[Music]
no
i'm sorry that uh
well well we barely couldn't have to go
out of business for us to
want to teach you knockers
[Music]
um
so you're an austin uh regular you
you've been here
i have no idea
i mean so i realized
[Music]
is uh got greek food
so you you just go all over you go to
south austin you go downtown
you go to barracuda which doesn't exist
anymore
you said it it's like there's like uh
what did you think of that actually
[Music]
wearing very large shoes right now
because i thought she was a pavement
that the soul came off of them and
somebody's clobbered him
oh what a shame that's the fashion error
that you made we're all laughing the
uh
17 it was for asian
4 11 5 wow that's uh sure
um
ryan how tall are you
uh i like five eight
i
he doesn't want to make an error because
i think like cody he can be stopped by a
woman
look at that
i mean you were stopped by monica moran
on
he knows the dishes ladies
um
how do you uh how did you meet monica
what is that love story
it's a it's a beautiful story uh we met
on an app
you know we found each other mutually
attractive uh liked a paragraph and uh
you know met up in real life and here
here we go taskrabbit
[Music]
i was hoping someone could clean my room
and she was up for the challenge and you
know every single thing
like uh you know she's not taking out
the trash and just getting the tasks
[Music]
it would be more like you know people
pay me for this and that's like that's
that's true
all right i'm trying to get her getting
it from for me getting approved
[Music]
but
[Music]
with the volcanic anyway not serious
typical but
uh i like all key countries
of countries like
outlaws
jonesy whales
okay it's the name that i associated
without my country
i thought i'd throw it in there i was
getting a little bored
um so
if you were to go on a date with ryan
this opposing tv that's accurate you
said it right it's a doze
what does that does
now it's polish
it's just
what local band do you think this
happened like
what
okay but your favorite band is a
christian band no no they're not
actually i think she's judging me out
life
god appearance you like jesus follow him
all the way
do we have the stuff thank you
what do you do ryan uh i'm in sales
okay let's say that uh
you're trying to get a girl you're
trying to get madison
dark
let's take your driving at madison arm
to a christian rock concert
try to sell her on that impossible thing
to sell
uh
how do you feel about the damnation of
your soul
do you want to go to heaven
do you like music
are you free on friday
friday friday flight day
hey good night for writing
did you publish something
please suspend your disbelief lady
uh that was uh that was a date with
madison dark and ryan this dog
christina robert
simon's friend christina go on day with
david
david
[Music]
here we go david's coming up
friend
uh
you know i would put a blood into a
sport fast
oh i don't know it's very bad basically
i'm very tall
singular
[Music]
have you thought of bringing simon's cat
with
your date
kind of pets are you going to bring on
the paddleboard
i'll forget that
could you get a cat just to go
paddleboarding with it
it's like a guy dog blind people
you
he said buffalo in florida
so
you didn't what's orlando magic right
yeah
you can say
it's like
lando magic
the thousand
[Music]
the salt guy in florida
yeah
twitter he has a twitter
why not online
thomas is
[Music]
[Music]
are you korean
that's pretty weird
uh
so how can i help you today
accomplish every asian man's dream
i'm speaking with another asian
[Music]
oh
she's an american
and now the banker
stroller yeah that's like the age of
hispanic maybe
[Music]
[Music]
your classmate when i'm cast
david's
[Music]
if you hear that on a date that means
you're about to get just so much
kevin my sister's about to just make so
much money
he always used to play with velo and
stitch in the office even though they
still got sure
i haven't heard
[Music]
i didn't do that before
i'm promoting fans she makes a lot more
money than i have than the year
happy meal he lives in a van
i'm moving into the house
congratulations
thank you
i would love to explore the wonderful
world of tennis rights in texas
there are another
about to be evicted
brian what's your favorite disney movie
that you would play in your orthodontist
office or bonnie's sister
well she's going to just go man
peter pan wow going for the classics
i really watched a lot of disney movies
i used to watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay i know exactly what that is
the girl asks you if you're a keeper
just say yes
[Music]
um
so uh christina
do you what's your what kind of sport do
you play
oh my god you're just like monica
yeah you look like uh you're ready to go
on npr tiny desktops where this is
possible
ultimate i'll take that
that's a prestigious honor for musicians
watch
it's like the other people copy show
positions
what do you think about this one korean
couple
they're not my favorite as far as
chemistry goes to each other out of all
the dates tonight
but i think there's some promise i think
you guys both seem sweet and
i think you guys can
laugh at yourselves but thank you very
much i hope you know oh
david
23 and you watch peter pan as a kid
so what is wrong with you the vhs player
and your dungeon keeper
you can school him you know
that's uh
pants are very tight i will say that
they are a little tight
i think um if you just got a little bit
bigger pants the date might have got a
little bit
she was focusing in on the horse
on your jacket yeah you want that focus
to be on your balls all right
yes don't bother morris
the fabrics why is the logo for the
mavericks of horse chances to be like
a fighter pilot
you know
i'll buy you pants
[Music]
i'm sorry ladies this is
okay
brian
um well that was the show
we have to end
at 7 25 should we do one more
we got scotty
chelsea l
tracy alexander
[Music]
hey
um
they're looking for that type
because they dance but you
they do don't
you have to like catch great i did
well that's what i'm saying is people
like you know disabled
sure
who doesn't man
stop hitting each other it's painful
no it's a beautiful day
ghosts almost you thought he was
roasting you i just had that one joke
and
blm put my name in there nice
you're a comedian right now yeah
[Music]
right you just love the crap so much
it's true
it's true i've been waiting to see
comedy shows for the last three months
i see you everyone
well let's hope that no one ever puts a
dick on dude
[Music]
[Music]
do you know what consent mean
where when did you grow up what was what
were your formative years it's born in
february of 80 so i don't know i
could have been born in the 70s
yes children's merchandise
uh scotty
what an interesting fellow you are
you say you're a butch lesbian male
so you feel a lot of feminine qualities
pastry chef
i love grass
is
have you ever had a
homosexual uh escapism
no you're not
actually well done
[Music]
if it was awesome
if you could make her one pastry to
impress her what would it be
oh
[Music]
because it's like four ingredients and
it's really hard to make but i bet it's
hard
it turned out
where are you from philly
houston what is it
you know talking about it outside you
were talking about how your dad never
laughs at your jokes
insurance coming to therapy yes dude
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
he could be your dad
like if i saw you guys out at a
restaurant that's what i think because
he doesn't look rich enough to be like a
trigger daddy
seems like
and i was like actually
let's keep going
hi
oh okay i thought you got zoo germs over
here
ain't nothing wrong with a little white
trash
i'm from
virginia yeah
i'm awake a guy i'm a comedian
you just saw brian up here that's the
finest specimen in korean i've ever seen
too much
anyways
remember my
like bars
where do you frequent like what do you
do for nightmares
to like boot scooters really asking
i in the day
give like together so now it's like
hopefully they got nice lights out there
it's all reproductive they got nice
pictures of the wall
it's uh
even you know
at least i know where i'm [ __ ]
he knows what he's doing here
i'll tell him
can you all be there
that's awesome
we already knew that by your uh beard
and blah blah blah thank you for
confirming see you later um playing
called the pastries
[Music]
what
yes
thank you guys so much for coming on
that was the show uh molly what did you
think about the uh dates tonight i mean
anyone stand out in particular i've like
started a lot i'm trying to remember my
favorite one
i think
no elise was definitely not
my mom could probably use it
we're gonna next next show we're gonna
have a dance battle between molly's mom
and enemies
yes
madison was great maybe you could close
up the show with a little dancing
okay
let's not let these ruin the show again
billy was great chelsea l scotty david
[Music]
us let's check your clues all right uh
if you went up for molly vivix
i'm not going to tell them
i don't know
hitting them so much well it's not
instagram other
people against somebody's in sex
i don't know ain't suspicious
the health department is requiring all
food establishments on this train to
close immediately if the city will be
shutting off the water to repair water